[Applauso]
buongiorni stimo caffè
parleremo di social socievoli
vi è mai capitato di stare al bar o al
ristorante questo non mi serve e vedere
quelli del tavolo vicino che appena
riceverà una portata tirano fuori il
telefono scattare una foto la
condividono subito danni ecco io non
c'entro niente con loro io magno quindi
mettiamo subito in chiaro una cosa io
non sono un social media coso ok non
sono un influencer non lo dico con
spocchia vorrei esserlo non me lo posso
permettere
e non solo nativo digitale sono infatti
nato nel 1985
in quell'anno nasceva anche il punti ti
si fondevano i primi domini.it proprio
compagni di scuola io il punto it
infatti stiamo festeggiando il nostro
genetliaco il 34esimo genetliaco capite
che già dico genetliaco sempre un
triceratopo del digitale no i nativi
digitali sono quelli nati dopo il 1985
effettivamente io vengo da quell'epoca
in cui si approcciava il web in maniera
molto molto diffidente cioè vi ricordate
quando mettere il nostro nome e cognome
vero per fare un indirizzo mail o
accedere a una chat
era una cosa impensabile pericolosissima
infatti miei decisero di non installare
nessuna rete a casa e quindi i miei
primi approcci web avvenivano in segreto
in questo modo che era il
parallelepipedo dove convergeva
l'internet che era il primo internet
point della mia città andavo in segreto
numero uno dei pochi che andava andare
lì utilizzare l'internet mi rendeva
nettamente superiore a tutti i miei
coetanei perché io riuscivo avere delle
foto di spock del capitano kirk che ne
ha viste le sognavano
ma quali amici amici a cui non fregava
niente di spot del capitano kirk era
vivo un calcetto il motorino e capita
che se sei vulcaniano ma nasce in una
qualunque provincia italiana comunque il
mondo intorno a te non ti sembra proprio
alla tua portata no non riesci a trovare
tantissimi stimoli
però avevo circa 12 anni non potevo
tornare subito al mio pianeta e quindi
ho deciso di utilizzare quella finestra
che era l'internet per soddisfare tutta
quella mia sete di sapere tutta quella
curiosità che avevo e così andavo a
curiosare io sono curioso l'avete capito
non potete dare qualunque accezione
vogliate la parola curioso e sono tanto
curioso e sono anche tante tante persone
infatti la mia curiosità mi ha portato
ad essere un architetto no alla foto da
architetto bianco e nero sguardo triste
che non metti a fuoco niente
sono stato un musicista e se non lo
sapete è colpa vostra guardate curde di
genti ai miei concerti una calca e
comunico tantissimo sui social network
ora potrei parlare ore di ognuna di
queste mia personalità ma oggi parlerà
di quella più seria di quella qui ed ho
più dedizione da quelle che ha più
responsabilità ovvero che comunico
tantissimo sui social network e in che
modo comunico comunico in maniera
ironica e il mio piano comunicazione è a
caso quindi io faccio tutte cose a caso
quindi nel mio canale ci sono dei
tutorial a caso che sono di tutorial di
fai da te dove non si capisce quello che
faccio che nessuno li ripropone a casa
ok
condivido la mia dieta a caso che come
potete vedere proprio nessun effetto
faccio di giochi a caso con quelli che
io non riesco a chiamare follower perché
quello che è parte che paura non ti
seguono e che se siete matti
no ma con i miei amici e io rispondo a
tutti parliamo tanti con la mia
community non dico famiglia perché se no
mamma s'arrabbia però la mia grande
famiglia
e tra una risata e l'altra mi chiedono
ogni tanto perché il lavoro fai bene
oggi per la prima volta al mondo nella
mia sto dicendo davvero che lavoro
faccio questa slide me giro scusa delle
spalle ma avremo legge allora sono un
esperto di prototipazione rapida e
manifattura digitale e faccio il
technical manager in un fabio che si
trova all'interno di un incubatore di
impresa mi occupo di innovazione dei
processi per le aziende collaboro con
l'università come local innovation
committee in un progetto europea
supporto e la blue economy sono anche un
maker e quindi collaboro con la maker
faire di roma uno dei più grandi eventi
di innovazione d'europa e faccio il
docente scuole di ogni tipo con questo
educazione digitale del 3 dic open
source software di grafica cade
modellazione tridimensionale con la mia
circolare tutto ciò che riguarda il
mondo della sharing economy chiaro no
si capisce niente
per questo la mia comunicazione molto
molto leggera
io non voglio mai parlare del mio lavoro
online però il mio lavoro
tutto ciò che in realtà sono non sono
altro che mi bombardo il cervello di
informazioni quelle informazioni di cui
la maggior parte la trovate su google
ok e cerco di trasferirle nella maniera
più semplice e comprensibile possibile a
qualche persona bisognosa di queste
informazioni
ok quindi io spesso spiego come
funzionano dei macchinari complessissimi
perché quando vediamo le cose da fuori
sembra tutto incomprensibile e poi se ci
buttiamo in una disciplina
dopo un po è tutto semplice può essere
tutto semplice e quindi cosa faccio io
nel mio piccolo ma insieme al digitale
l'internet vediamo tre big diamo
strumenti a chi non li ha ok quindi io
spiego un macchinario spiego un software
racconto che ha conosciuto 15.000 start
up che fanno qualcosa di simile a quella
che è la tua idea e chissà magari entri
in contaminazione con loro abbiamo
strumenti a chi non li ha perché quando
tutti avremo gli strumenti forse
emergeranno solo delle migliori cioè
facile dire che sei il migliore quando
c'è qualcuno che non può permettersi uno
strumento che non conosce uno strumento
quindi il mio ruolo è quello di dare gli
strumenti uno strumento voce l'avete in
tasca no penso che lo abbiate capito
oggi che il cellulare importante dai
talk anche precedenti noè quello che
comunicate io però vi voglio raccontare
un altro pezzetto della mia vita
dove a partire da questo strumento
insignificante un po odiato che però
teniamo sempre in mano ho cambiato tutto
ottobre 2016
in una manciata di secondi esattamente
io penso la mia casa il mio ufficio e di
conseguenza il mio lavoro non ero solo
in questa disgrazia c'era chi stava
peggio chi stava meglio di me comunque
in totale eravamo circa 41.000 persone
in tutto il centro italia
ora lungi da me spiegare come va
affrontato il terrore l'ansia la paura
lo sconforto non c'è un manuale ognuno
lo fa in modo suo la mia via all'ironia
quindi continuerò con ironia raccontarvi
di questa storia io ho visto che di una
totalità delle persone che subiscono una
catastrofe il 50 per cento se lamenta su
facebook
ok di solida e così quell'altro 50 per
cento un po più riflessivo online e
offline
se lamenta di quelli che si lamentano su
facebook io non avevo nulla di cui
lamentarmi perché io avevo soltanto
voglia di fare perché fare fare subito
non ti fa pensare
e in quel momento è meglio che non pensi
ok e quindi però pensavo io sono sempre
davanti al computer ma che posso fare
quando succede una cosa di questo tipo 2
andare a raccogliere macerie ricostruiti
casa con le due mani andare non lo so a
costruire una stalla per gli allevamenti
delle montagne non lo puoi fare non sei
uno della protezione civile non ha mai
fatto un corso di pronto soccorso non lo
puoi fare e quindi gli ho detto ma non è
che dietro quei tasti che premo sempre
riesco a trovare la soluzione a questo
problema
così ho fatto questo post su facebook
che in soldoni se non lo volete leggere
dice ho qui abbiamo perso tutto lei che
qualcuno la voleva la mano a ricostruì
tutto entro che so dopodomani e quando
premuto invio mi sono sentito veramente
scemo perché ho detto ma che che che
appello è che cosa sto facendo
sarebbero arrivati in spot che il
capitano kirk stavolta a salvarmi
lo faranno beh 21 giorni dopo quel mio
pass su facebook
debutta dalle marche che è un portale di
e commerce che raccoglieva al proprio
interno tutti i commercianti aziende
agricole piccoli negozianti e piccoli
produttori che avevano tantissima merce
rimasta nei propri negozi inagibili nei
propri magazzini e che stavano per
affrontare il periodo di natale con
tantissimo invenduto ho deciso di
aiutare loro perché se si ferma
l'economia si ferma un po tutto
effettivamente quando c'è un'emergenza
di quel tipo sono poche le persone che
iniziano a pensare appunto alle attività
economiche non la prima urgenza è
abitativa e quindi nasce questo sito
come ho fatto a fare questo sito
io poi no immaginate beh perché il mio
grido al mio grido di taglie marche
datemi una mano fatto dal mio cellulare
in realtà hanno risposto 130 volontari
da tutta italia
ho visto cose che voi nemmeno immaginate
gente di torino urlare dai e marche ti
dà una mano e di torino che te frega e
ho visto veramente tantissima
solidarietà da tantissime persone che
non è che hanno detto bravo grande hanno
detto io ti do una mano
io ci sto se mi scrivi alle 3 di notte
perché ti manca qualcosa di questo sito
io ci sto e questi 130 volontari sono
andati in giro a raccontare tutte le
attività coinvolte a raccontare le
storie delle persone che poi
commercializzavano i propri prodotti
tipici su tagli e marche 130 volontari
hanno quindi mappato raccontato
fotografato circa 200 io li chiamo
fornitori parliamo del negozietto
parliamo del piccolo produttore di
formaggio parliamo di tutti negli con il
ciauscolo io avevamo e abbiamo venduto i
nostri prodotti a 1.890 persone quindi i
nostri clienti consapevoli perché
consapevoli alcuni hanno comprato da noi
prima che mettessimo i prodotti online
perché già la notizia stava andando
oltre quelle che erano le nostre
possibilità e ci hanno dato fiducia da
subito e in 24 mila che caricavano sui
social
quando ci avevamo un momento di
sconforto questione stava dagli tutta
san marco ovunque ormai era tutto dai e
in quel periodo è il nostro sito per
alcune frazioni di secondo raggiunto
anche i 170 mila utenti simultanei
quindi per farvi figurare un numero
soltanto perde secondi siamo stati
amazon italia
ok questo significa 10 mila scatole
vendute in un mese per un fatturato di
300 mila euro fatturato ovvero non della
mia associazione ma questi 300mila euro
sono i soldi dal commerciante 1 i soldi
dati al produttore due perché erano loro
che vendevano i loro prodotti ma eravamo
soltanto un tramite digitale che gli
spiegava come utilizzare quel tipo di
mezzo però dagli marche per me non sono
numeri io sono un emotivo a me dei
numeri non me ne frega niente
dalle marche sono questi che sono i miei
compaesani e quelli del paese vicino che
prima italia marche forse salutava a
malapena forse è invece mi hanno
risposto che a facebook era contattati
via facebook il primo approccio è stato
quello nonostante magari stava accanto
al bar no e che sono diventati miei
migliori amici i miei collaboratori
comunque abbiamo fatto scatole giorno e
notte
comunque abbiamo attaccato milioni di
etichette e insieme sorridendo
ingrassando abbiamo affrontato il
periodo peggiore della nostra vita
io non auguro a nessuno una catastrofe
simile però credo con certezza che
quello fosse il periodo peggiore della
nostra vita
ebbene loro sono il prototipo di
fornitori che hanno venduto sul sito
dalle marche questa immagine ha più mi
fa anche un po commuovere perché queste
persone che volevano capire cosa stavamo
facendo ovviamente senza avere gli
strumenti per farlo
pensavano che vendere su internet fosse
un'attività impensabile è
pericolosissima ho raccontato questa
storia tantissimo ho girato tanto e poi
ha detto ma sarò solo cioè nel senso
solo io ho fatto questa cosa qui e ho
scoperto che partendo da un post su
facebook sono nate delle realtà
pazzesche
ad esempio mulino un me calabrese che ha
convinto centinaia di persone ad
acquistare l'ultimo mulino in pietra
della calabria per poter produrre dei
grani antichi e fare delle farine che
ormai sono quasi fuori mercato perché
molto molto pregiate ma perché hanno un
valore enorme
quindi è un'impresa sociale dove il
mulino lo gestiscono gli stessi
contadini
c'è chi prova e riesce a raccogliere
tantissimi fondi per curare dei mali
purtroppo rari
c'è chi prova anche a salvare il pianeta
o comunque a mandare un messaggio così
forte di allerta bene quello strumento
che ci abbiamo in tasca ha un potere
enorme
usiamolo consapevolmente quindi è facile
riuscire a sfogare la cattiveria in quel
tipo di mezzo no sembra distante sembra
un po staccato da noi è molto più
difficile molto più responsabile mandare
dei messaggi positivi
io faccio tutta questa comunicazione
ironica perché in realtà raccontare
ironicamente la mia giornata è la mia io
la chiamo la instagram terapia
immaginate che ogni due ore siete bombe
dico costretti però comunque dove
l'accendo intra telecamera perché
qualcuno se lo aspetta da voi e perché
vuoi anche farlo e devi rivedere in
maniera totalmente ironica per far
ridere qualcosa che forse in quelle due
ore è andato malissimo
quindi per me alla terapia cerco sempre
di mandare dei messaggi super positivi
fatelo anche voi ridete c'è troppa
cattiveria dilaga subito e veleno
attacca e brutto che non volevo
lasciarvi con tutta questa retorica sì
sto dicendo fate l'amore non fate la
guerra
e originale ok io che dire
vi ringrazio e vi dico ridete
condividete messaggi positivi e venite a
ridere sul mio profilo che magari tra
una lista dell'altra salviamo la
galassia che ne so
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]